so connectivity is more than just an
all-or-nothing affair we can talk about
how connected a graph is so let's begin
with two vertices two vertices are said
to be K edge connected if they remain
connected if you remove fewer than K
edges from the graph let's look at an
example so here's a graph and let's
focus on those two vertices that I've
highlighted in magenta they are one edge
connected because they're connected and
if you remove one edge they become
disconnected so they're one edge
connected but they're not two edge
connected if in particular if I delete
that edge then they no longer as a path
between the two magenta vertices here's
an example of two vertices these two
green vertices that are two edge
connected that means that I can remove
any number of edges less than toe which
is to say one edge and they'll stay
connected so I could try but if I do
remove two vertices they become
disconnected so with those two vertices
now those two edges judiciously selected
there will no longer be a path between
the two green vertices for a three edge
connected example we can look at these
two vertices highlighted in purple and
discover then we can remove any two
edges and they're still going to be
stuck together you can kind of see that
because they're in a cycle here and in a
cycle there and in order to break them
you're gonna have to break both cycles
which means of breaking two edges to
break two cycles and if you remove three
on the other hand you can't separate
them so if I cut these three edges I
might have been more obvious to cut that
one but I'm doing it this way to make it
interesting if I cut these three edges
then in fact I wind up with no path
between those two vertices so they are
two edge connected they are three edge
connected but not four edge connected
meaning you can remove two but you can't
three and keep them connected for a
whole graph a whole graph is connected
if every two vertices are kedge
connected and the point of this degree
of connectivity is to measure one one
motivation of it is it if you think of
this graph as indicating a communication
network where vertices are centers that
are sending and receiving data and an
edge corresponds to having some kind of
a channel or cable between adjacent
centers then connectivity is a measure
of how many of your channels or cables
can go down and still have the property
that every Center of information can
communicate with every other Center of
information so how many connections can
fail without cutting off communication
here's an example of a graph that
globally this is was the graph that we
saw before that has some vertices that
are one edge connected others that are
to other others that are three but the
graph as a whole is only one edge
connected because there's this one edge
that can be removed that splits it into
this graph on the other hand a
modification of it is two edge connected
now I can remove any one edge and no
matter what single edge I remove this
will remain a connected graph which
makes it two edge connected now there's
a corresponding definition of vertex
connected meaning it's K vertex
connected if you can remove any number
of vertices up to K and it will stay
connected if it's K vertex connected
it's certainly K edge connected but not
conversely if here's a graph that is two
edge vertex connected but one vertex
connected if you remove one vertex it
breaks if you remove that vertex it
breaks but on the other hand it needs
two edges to be cut in order to split
the graph into the complete graph on n
vertices is to cut it up and requires
cutting or n minus 1 edges
and in fact n minus 1 vertices to break
it up because everything is connected to
everything else so KN is as connected a
graph on n vertices as you can possibly
have but of course it's got a lot of
edges it's got n choose 2 edges or about
n times n minus 1 over 2 edges another
interesting structure is the
n-dimensional hypercube
so the square is a 2-dimensional in the
cube the the ordinary cube is the h3 has
has 8 vertices it looks like a cube and
in general the way we define HN is that
its vertices are the binary strings of
length n and two vertices are adjacent
if they differ in one bit they're the
same except that in one coordinate one
of them has a 1 and the other has a 0 in
that case you can make the edges
adjacent it turns out that the the n
dimensional hyper graph is n vertex
connected and this is worked out in a
homework or class problem so to
summarize well actually before we
summarize there's a basic theorem that
we're not going to prove it's just a
little bit too much of a challenge for
us to get into would take maybe a couple
of lectures is to prove mangers theorem
which says that a graph is K vertex
connected if and only if you can connect
any two vertices with completely non
overlapping different paths K of them so
if two vertices are K connected then
there are completely separate K separate
paths connecting them which means of
course that you have to cut each of the
paths in order to separate them and a
similar theorem goes for edge
connectivity so to summarize about some
graphs that we know about if given that
connectivity measures fault tolerance in
a network we're interested in
well how many edges did it take to
achieve this level of connectivity so
the number of edges is kind of a measure
of the cost and the complete graph on n
vertices is n minus 1 connected
it has about and squared over two edges
the hypercube now if we're gonna be
talking about graphs of size n to be
uniform the hypercube on HN has 2 to the
N vertices so if we want an end vertex
version we're talking about H sub log n
which has n vertices and then it has
about n log n over 2 edges so it's got
fewer edges than the complete graph but
a significantly less exponentially less
connectivity the grid is simply like the
XY axis or the XY plane with points at
integers so that every node is connected
to every two for adjacent nodes to one
up one down one right and one left now
of course when you get to the edge of it
if you make it finite the ones on the
edge you're only going to be Knut 2
connected so you have to wrap it around
in the shape of a doughnut to really
make it work with a finite graph but if
you do that then the thing is for
connected a four edge connected but and
only has two n edges and then a cycle is
two connected a cycle of size n is two
connected with n vertices and finally
trees which we'll talk about next time
on are the smallest possible connected
graphs they are one connected indeed
everything is in a tree is connected and
they only have n minus 1 edges but if
you remove one edge it splits and that's
sort of the summary of the K
connectivity story